the opcw functions on the basis of
declarations by member countries so they
have to declare whatever activity is
relevant to the convention and our task
as the Secretary of the OPCW is to
verify those declarations whether they
are correct or not sometimes they make
mistakes not intentionally but we ask
them to correct them and the overall
purpose is in fact to fully implement
the Commission so that every country in
fact can have enjoyed the security and
safety provided by this convention and
we didn't detect any violation of the
convention so far I which is encouraging
it has been already 16 years now since
1997 and we have 190 states and all of
them are sure in fact fulfilling their
obligations implementing the conventions
properly and so on and we have also a
very various activities of capacity
building as we call them so we train the
experts so that they can learn you know
how the the provisions could be should
be implemented we have a network of
laboratories where we analyze some
samples because all depends very much
also on technical means these experts
have to know how to analyze those
symbols when there is an allegation of
use of chemical weapons as it happened
this year in Syria and so our experts
went there to call examples and they
brought them to laboratories in fact
including Sweden and they were analyzed
and they determined unfortunate that
chemical weapons were used so this is a
very technical very scientific process
which is very reliable and we hope of
course that such incidents will not
repeat be repeated again but it happened
so our task is really to verify them to
determine them and to show that the
intern
asian community can act and take the
necessary measures to prevent them to
happen in the future